hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna do something a little bit
different I don't think we've ever
dedicated an entire show to planning but
it's gonna be collaborative planning so
I expect and I hope that there will be a
lot of input from you and I'll start out
by giving you a rough sketch of what I
think we should do to deploy the various
parts of this project that we've been
working on for four months now and then
I want to get your input to see you know
is that plan even reasonable is there
something I'm missing but maybe
something that could go wrong or some
better way to do it and then I'd like to
take each piece and come up with a
back-up plan because you never know what
could happen so I want to have a
fallback and this will all be in
preparation for the upcoming launch in
June and I figure once we break things
down and have a plan then in future
streams we can dedicate a stream to each
piece of the plan deploy it all together
I'd also like to maybe do some tutorial
videos that aren't live that are a
little bit more well thought-out and
don't include all my normal mistakes so
after we do a stream then and I get it
to work
then maybe I'll repeat the process with
a test you know version and then have
that video on my youtube channel that
way it'll be a little bit easier if you
ought to go back and and reference if
you want to do it yourself okay so great
looks like we're up to a good amount of
viewers here so I do want to say last
week I didn't stream very much I think
only once that's because I was at the
road
in conference in Virginia Beach which
was an awesome conference and I think
buddy gets a chance to go to that
conference next year I definitely
recommend it one of my favorite
conferences the people there were very
nice and I attended a whole day of
workshops on the second day of the
conference and learned some really
awesome things like I built an Alexis
Gill which actually got accepted and
it's live now so it's just a basic skill
called weirdin weird in faxes w dir tos
and weird some facts and we're team is
my hometown so it just gives you some
you know random facts about my hometown
so that was kind of my first first
Alexis skill kept it really simple and
then in my other workshop that's where I
got a lot of the ideas that I'm gonna
share with you today so shout out to
Francisca I don't remember her last name
no you know what I I gave her a
shout-out in the tweet my latest tweet
so check it out if you wanna see your
name and she works for Google and she
gave an awesome workshop on a lot of
Google cloud stuff and we built a little
a little note app on Google cloud so you
can check out that sweet if you want to
know more about her and I think we're
gonna get started so the way I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna set a Pomodoro timer
during that time we're just going to
talk about and discuss things related to
deployment if you have any other
questions so general coding questions or
really anything in general you want to
know my favorite color go ahead and ask
it but I'm gonna save those questions
for our five-minute breaks and then I'll
save it for the very end of the stream
once we get through all the deployment
stuff and then that way that will help
us stay focused a little bit but you
shouldn't have to wait too long to get
your question answered Oh awesome
Franziska is here I hope I'm pronouncing
your first name right let me know if I'm
not I really would like to pronounce it
right and great so if I mess anything up
in terms of Google cloud stuff hopefully
you know you'll be able to correct me
there so let me start this Pomodoro
session if you're not familiar with
Pomodoro session it's it can vary a bit
but it's usually 25 minutes with a
5-minute break all right so I'm just
going to do this in markdown I thought
about opening up Google Doc or something
to kind of markdown my plants or write
up the plans but I thought hey like we
do coding why not do it in the S code
and work them so it'll look prettier on
the right-hand side so if you'll follow
along you can check that out
and here's I'm gonna go down through and
just give you my my vision for how this
is going to deploy so let's take that
react part first so we have our react
project which is you know node we have
Express running we we built that out
with next js' we're using apollo for
graph QL so if y'all seen any of the
streams you know you know how that is
we've already successfully deployed it
using now which is from the same company
that makes next J is its site so that's
this really easy deployment it's scales
it's fast I want to use that because
then that takes away the burden of
server maintenance I love the fact that
it scales so it should be able to handle
whatever traffic and updating things is
super easy there's no downtime so that's
the the strategy now so let's go and do
a small heading for all these sub plans
so let's just call this the the react
app will do a small heading and then
we're just gonna do a list we're gonna
say now this is gonna be our deployment
so that one's pretty simple
I think that one is not really going to
be where the debates at although nikki
says is your mic pointed at your pc okay
you know what my mic did fall down a bit
it came loose so I didn't notice it
until you just said that me there we go
I hope that's better
I'm gonna move it a bit closer to me as
well and away from my my computer
alright cool so that should be better
sorry about that I'm gonna do my best to
keep my eye on the live chat to see if
there's anything related to our
deployment all right so now the next
part we're gonna do so let's do react
the next part is going to be our
[Music]
database so soup in my sequel database
and I'll go in and fill out the rest
here
okay so this is a good layout for kind
of the structure of what we'll need so
for our my sequel database right now
it's linked up on a digital ocean
droplet so we have one droplet it's just
a cheap $5 droplet and it has our
WordPress installation any files
associated with that and then it also
has the my sequel database all right
there so I don't want to keep it like
that
the reason being well obviously a
five-dollar droplet is not going to do
it we'd have to increase the size of the
droplet significantly but then that also
provides us with a single point of
failure
we could stay in digital ocean and one
option that I have thought of and this
could probably be our backup is to use
multiple droplets so we would have
multiple instances of my sequel and
WordPress and load balance between them
and then somehow make sure they're all
in sync at all times to me that's a lot
of work for some and it's something that
I've never attempted before so that's
why I say probably better for a backup
oh no I'm not showing my screen I'm
sorry anyway here's what I've been
typing so sorry I'm just I'm really
excited about this so I forgetting
little things okay so here's where we're
at so for a react app we're gonna use
now as our primary and we'll also come
up with some backup for that as well so
there we are thank you for saying
something
who said Stephen said I can't see the
layout you can't see okay so it looks
like a lot of you said you can't see the
layout oh so sorry
it's been a while since I've done that
one forgotten to show the screen but it
happens you'd think after a year doing
live streams over a year now I would
remember that but still don't okay so to
solve the complexity issues of having
multiple databases and trying to keep
them in sync I thought why not go with
one of these cloud hosted database
services so there are several options
out there because I did a workshop with
Google cloud I think it would be easier
for me and I'd be a little bit more
comfortable if I went with Google's
cloud sequel stuff so let me show you
what I'm talking about I'll paste the
link in for you because I have this up
at least I did have it up I'll put it
and close it up oh no here it is let me
go back I'm actually in the console to
start setting it up so I want to back up
and go to just kind of like the sales
page and info page for it so here's what
what I'm talking about when I'm talking
about the cloud sequel okay so it's a
part of Google cloud and I'm gonna paste
this into the chat the live chat so
y'all can check it out if you want and
if if you click on that and it doesn't
take you to the right place please try
copying and pasting it there's often
some issues with the links if you paste
them into the live chat so this will
definitely work we're obviously gonna go
with the my sequel option but here's
what I feel apart that really stood out
to me as to why I want to do with with
this fully managed write so automatic
backups right that's that's awesome
automatic updates right those are two
big things that we need to have that I
won't have to worry about anymore and
you all would have been watching for a
while you know that it I get pulled off
projects and onto other projects and
have deadlines so it's very easy for me
to forget
stuff like that that really nobody else
is gonna nobody higher up and is gonna
say like make sure you do those updates
they're not even gonna realize we need
up the hits or we need backups or
anything the only time anybody is gonna
be worried about that is if something
wrong happens and then they'll say well
didn't we have any backups so having
that taken care of is gonna just free up
so much time and worry from me so that
alone I think makes it worth it but also
the performance like I doubt I'm gonna
be able to match that performance if I
just stick with setting up my own
droplets same way with reliability I
love this so digitalocean as far as I
know I haven't researched myself but a
colleague of mine here has researched
the security certificates on
digitalocean and they are okay but they
definitely don't rise to this level of
security so I mean look we're not gonna
do anything HIPPA related but if we
wanted to we'd even be good for HIPPA if
you're not familiar with that here in
the United States at least if you're
doing anything with people's medical
data you need to be HIPAA compliant so
it's it's kind of a pretty high level of
security that's required so basically we
have all these certificates and more if
you dig into the documentation there's
even more certificates that I can
present to auditors when they come in or
let's say like the head of the IT
department here and say you know if
there's ever any question about well how
we set this up I can say listen all of
the data we have for the site is in a
secure place you know it's these
certificates are provided so that's it's
not always a big deal depending on who
your client is or what you're working on
but here in this setting we do go
through data security audits and things
so it's definitely important for me to
have that okay so that's just a little
overview I'm gonna check the live chat
see if there's any questions
all right I don't see anything yet which
I mean which is okay I guess it's good
so I guess that means what I've been
saying so far makes sense so we're gonna
we're gonna go over here and I'm gonna
say Google cloud sequel will be our
option one oops
click in the wrong place okay so that's
gonna be our option and I want you all
to think of some backups cuz I told you
backup that I thought of doing but
realistically I I don't want to have to
do that with with the short amount of
time we have until launch I'm not
confident that I can get that working
reliably in that amount of time okay now
we also have WordPress right so for
WordPress it's currently on that same
digitalocean droplet that we talked
about a few minutes ago okay we did just
a Phoenix just said you tweeted that you
want to discuss something from ref conf
here yeah so the idea is that I'm
getting for the cloud sequel database
and then also down here for the files
and images which we haven't gone over
yet I got those ideas from Francisco's
workshop at Rev Kampf so that's what I
want to talk to you mainly about if
anybody has any other questions about
ref conf let me know we can get to those
later I'm thinking about maybe doing a
recap video from ref conf and putting it
on my youtube channel links in the
description so I'd love to do that as
soon as I can realistically though I
will be very busy until the site
launches so I can't promise you that
that will come out soon but I'd like to
I'd like to at least make the video
while it's still fresh in my mind okay
so for the WordPress here's what I'm
thinking all right I've never done this
before but as far as I know it is
possible to host WordPress we
now so if you're not familiar with now
essentially it's not yet all right from
from my perspective from a user's
perspective with now a user being like
the developer right who's using now as a
service you type in a command on the
command line and your site is launched
that's it it's that easy if you want
your site to use a custom URL which we
will it's just another command super
easy deployments right so that's the
benefit of now and then you don't have
to worry about the server managing a
server or anything like that it takes
care of scaling all that so we are
already using this successfully for a
reactor but for WordPress what we need
though is to decouple from WordPress not
only the database but also the files so
to be honest with you I'm not a hundred
percent certain that we have to decouple
the files but I assume that you would
have to and I want to I've wanted to
anyway
so our my first idea here to go with
this is plan a is gonna be use now and
I'm just gonna say a backup our backup
plan is going to be digitalocean
and if you all come up with any better
backup plans please let me know but we
can still take out the files the
database and everything and go with
digitalocean and just do load balancing
on digitalocean
they set up so you can do automatic load
balancing we did that for way back for
project one last year and that works we
didn't use it with WordPress we use it
with react but it did work so at least
we know how to set up the load balancing
there so I think this is a decent backup
but not ideal due to some of the things
that
that I mentioned earlier okay so that
leaves our our final our final thing
here are the files so there's two big
reasons why I think we should host the
files somewhere other than you know on a
droplet tightly coupled there to our
WordPress installed number one we need
to migrate a ton of files from the old
system which is based on Ektron and is
currently hosted on campus here just a
few buildings away so I need to be able
to store those somewhere else and keep
the file structure it's I could do that
on digitalocean
I would have to get extra storage for
the droplet though and then again
there's the the whole management of it
right I still have to manage that number
two is when I want a user when a user's
gonna upload a file to WordPress right
so whether that be me or somebody else
in my department or even users from
other departments that we're going to
train over the course of this next year
after this launches we're going to train
go department by department do training
give them their own WordPress accounts
limited access so that they can update
their own content they're gonna want to
upload documents through and images I
don't want those to just go on the
droplet you know let's say it gets out
of hand people start uploading a ton of
really big things it could take up the
space on a droplet quickly I don't want
to go overkill and pay for a ton of
space but I also don't want to get taken
off-guard and fill up all the space in
my droplet so something like Google's
cloud storage buckets I think would work
better it would give us more flexibility
in terms of storage and it would have
availability so let me show you what I'm
thinking with Google's cloud storage so
again I have the documentation open and
like the sales page so let me go back to
the sales page here the sales page has
like the main points that you want and
the nice-looking graphic so that's why
I'm going with that products let's see
storage cloud storage I think I'm still
partially in the documentation part of
it good features all right I was kind of
open for a different page let me see oh
well I'll just go back to the page I was
on I I think it's fresh enough in my
mind that I can explain this a little
bit more without it and I did actually
have a storage bucket that I created
from the from the conference from the
workshop that we could go to if I need
to get into it a little more I don't
really want to get into technical stuff
but just say like essentially you could
see the prices think of like think of
Dropbox or Google Drive or Microsoft
onedrive right think of that but being
able to drop all your files in there and
have them available for consumption at a
URL for websites that's that's kind of
like what we have here and we're paying
a price per gigabyte per month okay
which I love that so that means we pay
for what we have in there if we put more
in there we pay more but we're not we
don't have like this fixed limit which
is what I was afraid of it I don't want
to over pay and I also don't want to get
stuck so this will allow us to scale
nicely I can come in on a regular basis
and clean things up if I
and say like yeah we don't need five of
these images or so-and-so uploaded like
this gigantic 5k video or something
crazy and we definitely don't need that
so I I love that and I love the fact
that I don't have to worry about like
backups I don't have to worry about like
providing for that on my on my own like
maintenance to that server it's it's
taken care of so this is since I work
with this already at at Rev Kampf I feel
more confident working with Google's
product
I know Amazon offers similar product I
assume Microsoft us I'm not on unsure
though but I think given the timeline I
could probably set this up more quickly
than I could otherwise my department
already has a Google account setup with
billing attached so I just need to make
sure and talk to some people who
understand how the billing process works
here I try to keep myself out of that
because it's just a lot of extra
paperwork so I got to talk to my
colleague and make sure that we don't
get in trouble first for setting up this
account but I'd like to set that up soon
and I'd like to do that on the live
stream coming up soon so I'm just gonna
go with on here I'm going to say Google
Cloud Storage okay so these are mostly
just like the plans plan a right we
still need our plan B our backup plans
so that's kind of what I want to discuss
whether or not number one whether or not
these plan plan days are any good or if
there's something I'm missing and then
number two what should plan B be
especially if any of you have used any
of this stuff or something similar on a
real project I definitely want your your
input I'm gonna check my time or two so
we about five minutes and
and I'll get to some of the questions
that are unrelated let me scroll up a
bit make sure I haven't missed anything
I see let me take all right so so far I
haven't had any comments on this outline
okay so our own s says AWS s3 should be
good s3 is the storage stuff right
you know how AWS is and you don't you
don't know what anything means if
somebody already hasn't made a browser
plug-in that translate AWS is names into
something more reasonable than you
should somebody should make it maybe
I'll try to make it but I did work with
some AWS stuff as well when I did that
Alexis skill workshop realistically
though I think if if I'm gonna use
Google Cloud sequel and Google Cloud
Storage that's fine if I'm gonna switch
and do something with Amazon with AWS
I'd rather do AWS for both because
that's just one less account that I have
to worry about managing so I'm open to
it I just want to know what are the
differences between one with AWS and
that's Amazon Web Services if you're not
familiar with the with the name so going
with Amazon versus going with Google
what are the differences is there any
good reason to go with one or the other
let's see okay Nicki says Nicki doesn't
have experience but heard West bus and
scott told Linsky talk about cloud and
airy for image storage on the syntax
podcast Nicki also says that's a great
podcast you know what I haven't listened
to that one yet I'll have to add that to
my podcast actually I do want to give a
shout out to the tales from the script
podcast so the guy who does that podcast
I got to meet him and
hang out with them at ref conf and super
nice guy so check that out also there's
a podcast called darknet diaries if
you're interested in like hackers and
things like that in security check out
dark net diaries podcasts I've been just
listen to that on the way back from ref
conf and I listen to every episode is
that good so definitely check that out
okay our turn s says AWS s3 which is
their storage it has a good backup
strategy okay alright that's cool
definitely need to look into that
Stephen says West boss likes cloud nari
a lot I wonder now let me just say I
have no proof of this but if they
mentioned cloud nari a lot on their
podcast are they getting referral credit
or something for cloud Neri that doesn't
mean cloud Nerys not good it just makes
me wonder
okay back we got another suggestion
called Backblaze our NESH says AWS s3 is
the cheapest Oh Nikki says yes they are
they are sponsored and are upfront about
it okay
okay let me mark down some of these
suggestions for our storage here so
we're gonna add as potential options AWS
s3 we're also gonna add cloud Andheri
and then the last one that was mentioned
I'd never heard of a four back blaze
back plays okay so these are gonna be
our options that we need to look into I
don't have a ton of time to spend on
researching this so I'm just gonna look
into a little bit more so if you all
have some reasons why you would
recommend one over all the others let me
know that would be very helpful let's
see so let me I'm gonna do the five
minute break right now so during this
five minute break I'm gonna answer any
questions that are unrelated to our
current topic after that we're gonna
reset the timer we're gonna get back to
the discussion make sure we have backup
plans for each one of the thing the
pieces that need to deploy alright so we
have a lot of people saying hi I'm not
gonna go through everybody but if you
did say hi I'm saying hi back to you
right now I do see all the hellos let's
see
Oh Nikki said just published part two of
fresh dev environment blog posts so cool
everybody check that out if you can
Michael says you remember when your boss
used to go away to
building conference I've got a feeling
this is going to be like that
who some asked if I would make an
algorithm course I could I tell you
truth I might not be the best person to
make an algorithm course I mean I've
I've done them successfully but I
that wouldn't be top on my list of
things I would feel confident that I
could contribute something but I'm open
to it
I'll definitely add that to the list of
potential video tutorials and things
that I could make
okay Michaels Michael who's with us
frequently on the live stream is having
trouble with his internet which that's
that really stinks sorry about if you're
still with us sorry about that Michael
if you if you can't watch it now but you
can watch it later on you know
definitely just put your input into the
comments or DM me or something and I I
would still appreciate you know your
opinion on these things
okay Rick Adam says which book and/or
video titles are recommended for a
thorough base of software development
regarding object-oriented programming
sequel or SQL depending how you like to
say it our BDB design and scripting in
Java oh I don't I don't really know you
know cuz I don't deal with like Java at
all and I minimally deal with sequel and
realistically like you know I with react
I'm not really doing object-oriented
programming so I don't really know does
anyone else have any suggestions for
books or videos on those topics if you
do please let us know in the live chat
or if you're watching later on please
throw it in the comments to the video
Phoenix said I once listen to that
meaning the darknet Diaries podcast and
never again since I started having
thoughts about the dark about dark net
bad thoughts yeah well if you've ever
been tempted to be you know a bad hacker
then maybe that's not the show for you
and me too tempting
Lawson not three asks what's the
question basically our question now is
what are the best ways to handle these
different pieces of the deployment that
we need to do for a current project
that's project 5 in this video series so
in particular if you have any opinion
about any of these products for file
storage you know please let let me know
Francisco says as far as I know on
standard products like stories the large
providers are all equally good and
similarly priced it's probably simpler
if you have one provider for all your
services ok cool yeah I definitely agree
on having one provider for all the
services so and thank you for that ok so
cloud storage azor is expensive ok so
azure is maybe we didn't even have that
as an option so I'm not gonna add it in
right now nobody really suggests that it
but that would be Microsoft's version of
this Joshua asked why I'm using
WordPress for the front end what we're
not using WordPress for the front end
react is the front end WordPress is just
handling our content management I needed
something that was very user friendly
for the people that are gonna have to
edit this because we're going to have a
lot of people that have no coding
experience editing this so WordPress
does provide that I think a pretty
pretty simple user experience and it
also has a huge community of
developers you know that I can reach out
to if I need help to customize some
things I do that's somewhat of a
background in WordPress as well when I
freelanced I used to do a lot of
WordPress sites because it seems like
every small business has a wordpress
site alright let's go back and we'll do
one more Pomodoro session we may not
even take the whole session and then
I'll go back and make sure I've answered
all the questions here but I want to go
back and fill this list out a little bit
more so keep it coming with all the
ideas definitely appreciate it I've
already had a few ideas that but I never
thought of because I've never heard of
these services
all right Lawson on says all I know
about them is AWS seems easy AWS is the
most solid choice not considering price
or firebase is from what I've seen okay
yet so firebase being Google product I
don't think we'll need firebase though I
mean weird because we definitely already
have the data in a sequel database so I
would don't I don't want to convert you
know I don't want to switch it over but
that's why I'd rather go with a you know
cloud sequel my Amazon does have
something similar as well so we could go
with that
okay hard sear hey how's it going hard
[ __ ] as you can see on the screen these
are some of the options that were going
with for deployment for each part of our
of our project so if you have any
opinion on any of these please let me
know okay so keep the suggestions coming
I think I've gotten through all of them
I want to talk a little bit about backup
plans for some of these so for our react
app we may be able to go with if we
can't go with now for whatever reason
I'm not gonna speculate on why let's
let's just say it we can't go with now
our backup of course could be load
balanced
digitalocean droplets okay-y
digitalocean well we already have an
account with digitalocean so that would
be faster but realistically could we do
something with a different provider yeah
we definitely could you know Amazon
Google Microsoft or any other number of
providers we could probably do the same
thing for I like the digital Ocean has
really easy load balancing built in I
don't have enough experience with other
options to know if their load balancing
is as easy okay but this takes a little
bit more work we would have to keep up
with the updates and maintenance on all
these servers so that's why that's
definitely a back-up plan if anybody has
any other options for backup plans that
may be better than that please let me
know it says let's see
okay Bo Bo's here I didn't see so Bo
Karns who does a ton of stuff for the
free code Kent YouTube channel is here
so good to have you here and we have
some more opinions on what we should do
here so Winnie essential ocean has
spaces with backups as data storage as
well doesn't it you know what I believe
they do so I do believe digital ocean
has the data storage backups and things
too so maybe you know what maybe we
should add digital ocean here as well as
an option makes sense we already have an
account with them and I believe someone
else in my department has used the
storage and digital ocean so I'll be
able to talk to them and see what they
thought of it
buffin says are you looking also looking
for Network latency problem many times
we experience in some regions of the
world websites load very slow due to
Network latency we I'm I definitely want
to avoid latency as much as possible I'm
not sure other than trying to make my
site as small and fast as possible I'm
not sure what else I could do and in
terms of helping with network latency
mad Duchess says perfect timing for the
topic working on mine Thanks you're
welcome I'm glad I hopefully this will
be helpful to you oh okay
Stephen has a very reliable kind of
old-school method here Stephen says how
about a couple of thumb drives and DVD
our archives yeah we could add that in
the mix right
you know it'll def it'll be totally
offline we don't have to worry about
hackers getting ins stealing or
corrupting our data right now that would
be actually be hilarious just to have
like a little piece of artwork hanging
in my office that are like the entire
website and thumb drives or something
like that maybe I'll have it in glass
that says break in case of emergency
Harshit says by the way you will be
working using docker for WordPress now
yes
so that's let me let me just show you a
little bit of the details about how this
would would need to work
so I've already forked the example for
how to use WordPress with now so if you
check out this FUS mark on here I'll
give you a link to it so our
organization that we've been building
are all our stuff and now has a fork of
this so that we can modify it if we need
to but basically yes we we have a docker
file and that's where things things run
so if you see like this is where we get
all the WordPress stuff right and they
actually have SendGrid built in if we
need to do emails we not we aren't going
to need the same good part of this or at
least we aren't going to use it I'm not
sure yet if we need it
so that WordPress will still work there
are some parts of WordPress that auto
send emails you know to like people when
they sign in as users or to whoever the
admin is which would probably be me
whenever new users hot users sign in so
we may need the email just for that sort
of thing so might keep it but
essentially you know for those of you
who know docker this will make more
sense to you but these are all the
instructions to get WordPress up and
running within that docker container so
I need to spend more time kind of
studying this to figure out because
there are a few things in use here that
I've never used before so
Harshit mentions hhv em I've never even
heard of that before much less used it
so that's one of the things I want to
research more about
Harshit says it will be two times faster
than php5
hey well I like that any anything to
make it faster is good so so if anybody
knows a little bit more about docker and
can kind of see what's going on or you
want to use the link to you know to
check it out inspect it a little bit
more depth you know if you have some
some input for me that would be great
but this is the official example if you
go to the now documentation and you look
up WordPress this is where they point
you so it's it's at least trusted by the
now team to use with WordPress so I'm
kind of basing my confidence on on that
Michael Creole has a good point says not
sure how WordPress works when you
finally hand it off you're gonna need a
lot of validation rules if they're going
to be less experienced people working on
it I paraphrased a bit but yet yes
you're right
we're definitely that's why we're
holding off on giving other people
access right now and we're gonna slowly
roll it out and train people over the
next year one of the one of the big
reasons other than just the time it
takes for training is making sure that
we set it up in a way that users have as
much freedom as possible without really
the ability to mess things up too much
so we're definitely going to be working
on that
okay let me go back here and say so
basically we have our plans and then our
backups or everything except this Google
cloud sequel and I'm gonna put here as a
slash slash AWS because you know as we
mentioned earlier you know if we decide
to go with Google here we're gonna go
with Google you know down here as well
if we decide to go with AWS it's gonna
be AWS you know pretty much across the
board but as a backup let me know what
you think about you know essentially
doing something like this right load
balanced situation droplets and actually
let me change this to say load balanced
situation droplets here and now if
you're not familiar with with how we've
done this in the past essentially what
you do is have droplets that are exactly
the same so it's we've run a few
droplets that are exactly the same and
then we would use digital oceans load
balancing service which is an extra $20
a month and then they would handle a lot
of the technical details of it we would
just have control over a few settings
and then they would you know that the
load balancing would be handled so for
each time we do this for the react app
that adds an extra 20 for the database
extra 20 for WordPress an extra 20 so
that's an extra 60 a month that
potentially we wouldn't really need just
for the load balancing and then on top
of that we need the droplets so we'd
have to pay for each one of the droplets
so I believe that using now and some
sort of cloud service here would end up
being easier to manage and also less
expensive
also easier to scale we have a few more
opinions on this as well so let's see
Harshit says AWS RDS is also good easy
to set up use docker for my sequel with
volume but I guess that will be overkill
Francisca says I have to run thanks for
the stream watch we'll catch the rest
offline thank you so much for watching
and lending your opinion I really
appreciate it and again thank you for
the the workshop I love the workshop and
I learned so much it's gonna help me
with with my job so again thank you
that's that's awesome ok alright so at
this point I still want to hear your
opinions either now on the live chat or
later on in the comments if you don't
want to say anything publicly you can
always DM me on Twitter if you want but
I'm gonna go now and start reading some
of the other questions that aren't
directly related to deployment I did
have a comment from Harshit harsh it
says add AWS RDS to that list so we're
talking about the sequel list then
anyway I'm sure there's a little delay
but our should you let me know I
couldn't remember what the AWS
equivalent of cloud sequel was
so let me scroll up a bit so I don't
miss any of these questions so scan
through them
okay Chris asks if I've done anything
with CSS grid yet I've just done a
little bit with CSS grid so it's
something that is definitely on my list
of things to research more I would love
to know more I've actually found some
tutorials that I've like put in my the
links to in my google keep and like hey
I want to do this and then I just
haven't really had time to get to kind
of do it so definitely want to learn
more about grid because from what I've
heard from other developers like that's
that's where it's at okay so harsh it
says the AWS RDS stands for relational
database system cool that that's an AWS
name that actually makes sense right
relational database system definitely
makes sense
Harshit says I will catch up the stream
not sure why you need digital ocean
droplets on top of those services oh
these aren't the digital ocean droplets
this is the these are the backup plans
in case for some reason I can't do the
primary so on each one of these the
first option is what I want to do but if
that doesn't work out for some reason
there were other options or potential
backups so I'm not intending on doing
all of these things just one in each
category I keep I keep moving my mouse
on the wrong side this is the side that
y'all probably looking at
Joshua says what would you recommend for
a geolocation API that could tell you if
you are standing next to someone
I was thinking Google Places what was
looking for some feedback
trying to think I've used like Google
Google's geolocation stuff before but
it's been a really long time trying to
tell whether you're standing next to a
person might it might be a little bit
difficult to get that accurate like
trying to tell if you're within a
certain range of a person is definitely
doable I suppose
assuming that person also has the
location services enabled and you have
access to theirs but like let's say if
there's like five people that all have
that enabled I mean I don't I could yeah
now I think about it I think that's
definitely possible with with Google's
geolocation services
Harshit says you could easily spin up
RTS cluster that will give you certain
password added WP config and database
done yeah yeah definitely it's Harshit
that's what I'm hoping for the only it's
like I I'm pretty sure you do the same
thing with the cloud sequel so I'm kind
of like just wondering which one should
we go with I also want to talk to the
other developer that works in my
department to see what he thinks and he
handles the accounts like the billing
for the accounts so I want to see like
in his opinion what would be easier to
set up billing wise right now so that
may that may be a big factor as well
because I don't want to I don't want any
trouble in this process of getting all
the accounts set up I wanted to go as
quickly and smoothly as possible so like
I think either one of these AWS or
Google will work just kind of not
exactly sure which one to go with at
this point ok well I've gotten to the
end I seems like I've answered all the
questions if you have any more questions
throw them in here if you get them in in
the next minute or so I'll see them and
I'll be able to answer otherwise I think
I'll finish up with this stream and
probably do a little bit more research
on this and our our streams coming up
over the next week will assuming I can
get the billing and account set up soon
our next streams will be basically
deploying all this stuff
Joshua says thanks a bunch you had no
problem
mad Duchess it responding to someone
else says CSS tricks calm has awesome
tips for all CSS but also on grid there
are a lot of articles about CSS on that
site yeah definitely I've definitely
used some of the articles on CSS tricks
calm before that's a great resource
Robocop's is nice dream
thanks thanks I appreciate that all
right well I think I'm going to finish
up now and yeah if if any of you
watching later on or watching right now
think of something or some options or
warnings for me for this setup later on
please let me know DM a comment whatever
you want but you know definitely would
like all the input that I can especially
for those of you who have actually used
these projects before it can give me
some you know kind of good input that I
may not be able to read anywhere else
okay I think that's it I'm gonna do my
best to try to stream as many days as I
can this week and so hopefully I'll be
seeing you a lot this week to make up
for all the times I didn't stream last
week and so in until probably tomorrow
stream have a great day